thank you I'm diabetic with numbness
circulation problems tingling in my
extremities and I would like to make
sure that mom hears a clearing as I take
your products
okay here's ten top okay
these are asking them over and over what
they're over you 79
okay and how much you weigh about 150 to
150 one point simple attitude okay
that's close enough and you have any
other issues other than these if you see
some numbness and some that would you
call it burning or tingling burning
right right and I need to know what's
good you know sure thanks I'm swirling
around my ankles yeah did the doctor
give a diagnosis of anything like
peripheral neuropathies or ms range like
that neuropathy from diabetic nerve okay
so you have diabetes and that means I'm
diabetic with none the circulation in
latex okay relations on these legs and
feet okay gotcha all right no
circulation right okay so number one you
got to get rid of all the bad stuff all
the inflammatory things okay it's going
to help you a lot and get rid of all the
bad stuff that means no fried foods
absolutely no oils I mean no olive oil
coconut oil margins manage hundreds of
cooking oils noble process meats with
nitrates and nitrites that means no deli
slices the sandwich meats sausage ham
bacon Bologna salami pastrami pepperoni
jerky carby spam and absolutely no
gluten no we burn around oh no we
brought around oats and certainly
because you have diabetes is doing from
sugar cane ashlyn process that means no
juice no fruit absolutely no honey no
molasses no agave syrup
nothing like that alright can't have
that and then no gluten no we run around
oats I said that I'll say it many times
you see where's the gluten
at 152 pounds I would go ahead and take
two is a healthy brain and heart after
month two healthy brain and heart packs
per month the fold over think twice a
day I'd also get two bottles of what we
call sweeties each month so you take
three of those capsules twice a day
three at breakfast three to dinnertime
be sure to take your fasting blood sugar
every morning before you medicate
yourself or your bless you're going to
drop and as it drops to your doctor
taught you to begin to reduce your
medication the more your blood sugar
drops more you reduce your medication
and eventually get to the point where
your blood Sugar's below 100 your a1c
humans below five all right and without
medication that's what does your goal
here it could be anywhere from two weeks
tonight to 90 days two weeks to three
months is when it's going to happen then
as your doctor pointed out when you have
this burning and tingling and numbness
these are usually due to peripheral
neuropathy degenerative disk disease you
know if you shrunk any in height have
you lost an inch or two in height you
know mm lost any height my vigil
hemisphere at 79 years old I bet you've
lost some height and so why don't you do
it get barefoot probably so I'll
remember what the doctor the nurse
posted about my height but I'm like five
feet five I'm not that tall and I
probably don't weigh quite that much
haven't been to the doctor last three
months
okay would you listen to me now I want
you to get barefoot stand against the
door jam in the kitchen or the bathroom
have somebody else they can hold the pen
at parallel with the floor put it dot on
the doorjamb
and have them measure from the floor to
that dot okay and say your five one or
five three or whatever it might be okay
and then then talk to your kids to your
brother or a shirred call the doctor's
office is eight how tall do you have me
my first started going to you well you
know was I have five two and I'm five
footer I was 5 5 a 9 5 3 and I need to
know what it was and it started going to
you I want to know how tall I am now
okay because I okay now here's why when
you have
for neuropathies almost always 99% of
times you have the general gist kizhi
the district getting center between your
vertebrae the riverbay are getting
closer together and they're smashing the
roots of the peripheral nerves okay and
that's causing this burning and numbness
and tingling and so forth so what I want
you to do and again get rid of all the
bad stuff the pride through the process
meet you all the glutens said I want you
to take your body weight go ahead and
get to healthy brain and heart patch
them up to healthy brain and hard packs
per month full dose everything twice a
day I get two large bottles of glue a
gel two large bottles of gluco gel there
would be 240 count piles of blue gel so
you take 15 a day five it records five
at lunch five at dinnertime as 15 a day
and I go ahead and also get the CM cream
CM cream and the trauma multi are a um a
trajo I'll put 5 drops of trauma um no
TR TR a um a trauma like you get in a
car wreck thank you suffered from trauma
okay trauma loyal but five drops the
teaspoon of the CM cream mix it up real
good with a toothpick or a straw and
then either yourself or somebody else
apply that your neck your upper back in
between your shoulder blades and also
your lower back in your lumbar area for
the sciatic nerves are okay and you're
going to deal with the diabetes aside
taught you how to do that you take your
fancy closure every morning before you
medicate yourself adjust your medication
you've been taught to do and then I want
you to call me in two weeks in four
weeks and six weeks give me an update I
want to know how your numbness is
burning and tingling is doing I don't
know what your blood sugar is okay
compared to today and two weeks I want
to know what it is and three weeks or
four weeks um wonder what it is and so
on and we're going to walk you through
this